aquí tenemos un triángulo del cual
conocemos dos ángulos y un lado y yo
sostengo que puedo conocer las otras
partes del triángulo con esta
información si me dan dos ángulos y un
lado voy a poder encontrar el valor de
los otros dos lados y por supuesto el
del otro ángulo veamos cómo se hace esto
la manera de hacer esto es usando lo que
se llama la ley de senos la ley de senos
en un vídeo próximo vamos a demostrar la
pero por el momento sólo vamos a
aplicarla es un concepto muy simple la
ley de seno se estipula que la razón
entre el seno de un ángulo y el lado
opuesto a dicho ángulo es una constante
que es idéntica para los tres ángulos
del triángulo así por ejemplo para este
triángulo donde este es un ángulo de 30
grados y este es de 45 grados este
ángulo de aquí va a ser quedamos tienen
que sumar 180 grados entre los tres
entonces esto va a ser 180 menos 45
menos 30
estos son grados entonces es 180 menos
75 esto es igual a 105 grados
ángulo mide 105 grados así es que la ley
de senos pero antes deja de ponerle
etiquetas a los lados a este lado vamos
a etiquetarlo con la letra a o más bien
tiene longitud a mientras que este lado
de aquí lo etiquetamos con be tiene
longitud b la ley de senos nos dice que
la razón entre el seno de un ángulo y el
lado opuesto a dicho ángulo va a ser
constante para todo el triángulo así es
que para este triángulo aplicando la ley
de senos tenemos que se no de este
ángulo que es 30 grados dividido entre
el lado opuesto que es 2 tiene que ser
igual a seno de 105 grados seno de 105
grados dividido entre el lado opuesto
que es ad y esto a su vez tiene que ser
igual a seno de 45 grados seno de 45
grados dividido entre el lado opuesto
que es
es la ley de se nos parece triángulo
ahora si queremos encontrar a
simplemente despejamos a de esta
ecuación y si queremos encontrar d
despejamos b de esta ecuación resolvamos
entonces ambas ecuaciones cuánto vale el
seno de 30 grados te puedes acordar del
círculo unitario o los triángulos
especiales o si no sacamos la
calculadora recuerda hay que checar que
esté en modo de grados ya lo he hecho
así es que se note 30 grados 6.5 esto va
a ser entonces punto 5 sobre 2 un medio
sobre 2 que es equivalente a un cuarto
hemos hecho aquí esta división de un
medio sobre dos y esto es igual a seno
de 105 grados sobre a esto es igual a
seno de 105 grados sobre a y también
podemos establecer la otra ecuación que
esto es igual a esto es decir que un
cuarto es igual
seno de 45 grados sobre b y seno de 45
grados también es de los valores fáciles
de recordar por el círculo unitario o
por los triángulos especiales que hemos
mencionado seno de 45 grados es raíz de
2 sobre 2 también podríamos usar la
calculadora y obtendríamos este valor en
decimales en fin ya tenemos dos
ecuaciones despejemos de aquí la a y de
aquí la ve aquí podemos tomar de sí
pocos a ambos lados el recíproco de un
cuarto es 4 que es igual al recíproco de
seno de 105 grados sobre a que es a
sobre seno de 105 grados ahora
multiplicamos por seno de 105 grados a
ambos lados y tenemos que del lado
izquierdo queda 4 que multiplica a seno
de 105 grados y esto es igual
aa sacamos la calculadora para hacer 4
por el seno de 105 grados y esto nos va
a dar deja de ver
redondeando al nivel de centésimas esto
es 3.86 y es aproximadamente igual a
3.86 este lado a mide aproximadamente
3.86 que se ve correcto si este lado
mide 2 y los ángulos están bien medidos
calculemos ahora el valor de b tomamos
recíprocos a ambos lados nuevamente y
obtenemos del lado izquierdo 4 y del
lado derecho nos queda b sobre raíz de 2
sobre 2 multiplicamos entonces ambos
lados por raíz de 2 sobre 2 para obtener
que b es igual
a 4 que multiplica
a raíz de 2 sobre 2 recordemos que raíz
de 2 sobre 2 escena de 45 grados y vamos
a calcular cuánto vale entonces b b va a
ser igual a 4 por raíz de 2 sobre 2 que
es lo mismo que 2 x raíz de 2 y esto es
igual a 2.83 así que el valor de b es
aproximadamente igual a 2.83 para que
quede claro lo que hicimos 4 por raíz de
2 sobre 12 es lo mismo que 2 raíz de 2 y
esto es igual a 2.83 así es que de este
lado de aquí mide aproximadamente 2.83
que si aparece con el tamaño adecuado de
acuerdo a la escala que tienen los otros
lados del triángulo podemos decir
entonces que la clave para usar la ley
de senos es que si conoces dos ángulos y
un lado del triángulo puedes encontrar
los demás elementos de ese triángulo o
también si conoces dos lados y un ángulo
puedes encontrar todos los elementos del
triángulo y eso es lo extraordinario de
la ley de senos